hey what's up guys my name is Jonah and
welcome to episode 8 of network chat
programming so last time which was a
while ago we left off with having this
pretty cool window here where the user
could enter their name you know an IP
address so like localhost for example
and the port like a 1 1 2 for example
like we have here then they can hit the
login button and presumably you know the
client logs in and they're treated with
this window and today we wouldn't talk
about a few things we're probably going
to um talk about actually passing this
data into a actual login things you can
see that we pass it in here but um will
more or less talk about that a bit
further and also um first thing I want
to fix up here is this request focus
thing like you know what happens is when
we kind of launch this application and
we log in you know whatever Y on
localhost everyone Run 2 then we hit
login like the user can tap straight
away right there's no focus on this and
it's pretty easy to actually request
focus after we hit the set visible true
ok so right after that we actually up to
type the component we want so text
message is the name of our text field
and request focus in window
ok that's the proper way to do it
requests focus is a bit on it it works
but it's more or less platform dependent
might not work for all circumstances and
this also will not request folks to the
window just the component in the window
so if you minimize or something that's
not gonna appear you and harass you
so Cherno localhost a-19 - if we hit
login what we should see is as you can
see the window is straight away the
message windows is available for us to
type straight away so cool now let's
talk about how we can get the send
button right now or when the user hits
enter how we can actually get that to
post something into this text history
because this is a text history in fact
what we want to have here is a way to
write to this as like a console ok so we
might want to display a message being
like blah blah logged in at this time or
connection successful or connection
failed or connection or trying you know
what I mean like a console kind of
window so the user knows what's going on
so let's talk about doing that now so
what we have is this awesome text
history which is a J text area and we
need a function here in
client dot Java class now I'm a client
of Java is more or less a um it's it's
our window okay it's not actually
probably gonna contain any of the UM the
code to actually send messages and
receive messages and stuff
it's probably just gonna be there for
the purpose of displaying our window as
a graphical interface and because of
that all of our methods that actually
write at the console should be here so
we'll just make a public method here a
public void we'll call it um let's say
it's a client though we could call it
console okay and this would be like a
write line kind of print line to the
console thing and then we'll print
whatever we want so string message or
string text and then what we want to be
here simply type text area I think it's
called text history dot that's not it
okay it is that it's just not global so
make sure we take the text area here and
we actually um let's copy that and then
let's get rid of the text area here and
then we'll paste what we just copied
into the top here so private and then J
text area text history that will make a
global first class which is good here
and make sure the private because we
don't need to be accessing it from
anywhere else so text history dot come
on give you some uh there we go
oh let's text our history why the text
our history anyway I guess because the
text area I don't know who I we called
it that but anyway text area dope end
and there now message okay
now what this will do is append whatever
we want into the into the actual console
so let's test that out real quick when
we do create this and this is in the
create window thing here what we want to
do is let's just type in a text our
history dot no hang on we just made a
method for that let's type in console
and then we can type in something like
successfully connected you know even
though we don't know if it took self or
connected or not let's just type that in
anyway
so again we'll go yarn localhost a-19 to
hit login and you can see that it says
successfully connected now and that's
really cool now what happens if we try
to do that again okay what if we do too
so console and then let's do another
line and we'll call it successfully
disconnected I don't know just for fun
let's hit up that hit login okay you can
see it's on the same line not cool right
we want we want everything to be on
there on a different line so how can we
do that well if we go down over here
after append we can actually add in fact
I'm not sure if append will actually
have anything to do that now doesn't
have anything in the Javadoc but um if
we actually append to this message
literally here if we just type in plus
and then backslash n backslash ah that
will actually give us all just thinking
n is n his new line right and his new
line in consoles R is some more or less
kind of the same thing
but if we try that out and we type in
Yan localhost a one line to what we
should get is you can save them on
separate lines and that is pretty cool
you probably don't need both of them
there / and / I'm not quite sure that /n
would work I know / I will but you know
have both of them there for safety so
now we've got a way to write stuff to
the console okay and that's pretty
that's pretty cool okay so that's
probably gonna wrap up this episode what
we're doing as well which is actually
I'm kind of important here is we're
actually setting whatever our name is
into these variables so what I could do
is in fact let's do this quickly
6 so we could we could do something like
um attempting a attempting a connection
with and then we could add the name here
at hang on now
so at any connection with like Jana
smiles doesn't sound right does it
attempting connection for whatever no
hang on I am screwing up the English
part of this on I what sounds good
so attempting it attempting a connection
I guess to and then our server
which is address at we could probably do
just a : there plus port plus you know
user and then plus our name here okay
and now I guess that would look more or
less correct here make sure we have a
plus here as well okay cool so if we run
this and we go yarn localhost air one
lender then what we should get is as you
can see over here so attempting a
connection to local host a one winter
user yarn okay that's it and that
basically just demonstrates that we
actually have the ability to do this
stuff now one thing one other thing I
want to cover because this episode is
kind of short and I know you guys want
to say content every time we exist we
basically hit the send button we want to
grab the everything we want in fact I
might actually say that for a later
episode because it is a bit more
involved because we want stuff like um
the Enter key to work but what we'll
cover next episode probably is this this
text this text message history kind of
thing I think it's just called text
message but um this this field right let
me just make sure you guys can say that
this text field okay because we
essentially want people to be able to
type in like hi and then hit enter we
don't want them to be we don't want them
to hit Send like they can obviously if
they want to but we want them to be able
to hit enter so we'll cover keyboard
listening into this field next time so
so I hope you guys enjoyed this episode
of network share programming if you did
please hit the like button again same as
we've game programming series if this
hits 200 likes I'll release one video
per day not of this series just one
video per day in general of either the
game programming or the network chat
programming series if it hits two likes
then I'll release two videos per day
most likely one of each okay so make
sure you hit that like button if you
guys did enjoy this video later guys